i thought we'd talk about a tweet by
some guy called brady harren who put a
picture up saying what's going on here
so i thought we would talk about it
that's me that's you so there's a
rainbow there
but up there
there's like these double rainbows up
above the sun's over there
there's these double
rainbows
and then the normal one
that's kind of fading out there what
you're actually seeing is in a very
indirect way the structure of a molecule
this is an electron microscope picture
of a snowflake which has six fold
symmetry hexagonal symmetry to it i
don't really want to look at the
snowflake i want to look at these little
hexagons all around you see that little
ice crystals that form in the atmosphere
usually have this kind of hexagonal
structure to them in the 17th century
johannes kepler the royal astronomer for
emperor rudolf ii as was the way with
astronomers in general throughout time
the person who was supposed to be paying
him wasn't paying him so he had no money
and it was coming up to christmas and he
wanted a present for a friend of his and
he was kind of walking across prague in
the snow the snow was coming down and he
saw these snowflakes on his jacket and
became interested in the fact that they
had this six-fold symmetry to them and
so he wrote an essay about the six-fold
symmetry of snow which he gave as a
christmas present to his friend so it
was a cheap gift basically but in that
essay he talked about why it has this
six-fold shape he drew this sort of
analogy with beehives you know they have
the hexagonal structure inside beehives
and he pointed out that this is the way
that you can pack the most into a given
space the hexagons have this interesting
property that they'll kind of tessellate
together and you'll compact things as
closely together so we had this idea
that it was something to do with the way
that the smaller structures that went
into the snowflake what we would now
think of as molecules take up this
hexagonal structure because that's the
way to pack the maximum of them in and
indeed that's what's happening water
molecules arrange themselves in such a
way that they form little hexagons and
then the little hexagons join together
to form bigger hexagons and so on until
you get all the way up to snowflakes the
smaller structures that happen much more
often than snowflakes are these little
hexagonal sort of flattish hexagonal
shapes and they're what's responsible
for your halo
in any cloud you've got these little
hexagonal crystals forming and they tend
to orientate themselves flat just
because that's the stable thing if you
think about leaves fluttering down from
a tree and it's the same in clouds you
have these crystals form and as long as
there's not too much turbulence in the
cloud they'll just sort of settle into
these orientations so you've got a cloud
which is basically full of these little
hexagonal crystals all align like that
and then you've got the sunlight shining
on them they're not completely
transparent so they act like little bits
of glass or whatever they've got a
refractive index to them which means
that as light passes through them it
gets bent by them and in fact light of
different colours gets bent by different
amounts the bright arc that you're
seeing in the image that you took is
actually where the light from the sun is
coming in at sort of an oblique angle it
goes in through the top and then out
through the side but each time it goes
through one of those surfaces the path
of the light gets bent a bit because
it's passing from one medium air to
another medium ice why does it make an
arc so the reason it makes an arc if you
look at these things because they're all
aligned you think about it the lights
coming in it's hitting all these
different crystals at the same angle to
the vertical and then it's passing
through a surface which bends that
vertical angle a bit and then through a
horizontal surface which bends that
angle a bit more so the light came in
and then got bent a bit then got bent a
bit more so the light instead of coming
from over there is now coming from
higher in the sky it appears to be
coming from higher in the sky the one
thing that we haven't factored in is
although these things are all flat their
orientation in the other direction is
random and so that means sometimes it
comes out sort of perpendicular to one
of these faces and sometimes it comes
out at an angle to them that adds
another refraction so we the the amount
the light is bent in the vertical
direction is fixed but the amount is
bent kind of azimuthally around just
depends on what angle of surface it
exits through so the light is always
kind of coming from the same direction
vertically but gets bent around
depending on how it exits from that
vertical face of the crystal and so
that's why you see the light coming from
an arc
so that explains this thing as i say
which is called a circums xenothor arc
so it's circumstantial because then it
is the straight up direction and it's
around the zenith they all come from the
same direction relative to the vertical
but different angles around so you end
up with an arc straight up is up here
somewhere and so this is a circle around
straight up this thing is actually much
rarer that's called a supralateral arc
and that occurs because so although all
the crystals that water forms at least
that sort of atmospheric pressure have
this hexagonal symmetry they don't
always end up as these little flat
things that's the most common thing but
another possibility is they can actually
grow into cylinders cylinders also tend
to orientate themselves in a particular
direction they tend to orientate
themselves with their long axis parallel
to the earth
you've got the light coming in through
one of the long sides and then out
through the flat end but in this case
you can see that the all kind of being
bent around an axis which is parallel to
the earth rather than perpendicular to
the earth the thing that you can change
in this one is you can rotate that
cylinder around which means that the
light always gets bent around the kind
of a horizontal axis but what angle
around that horizontal axis it gets bent
to depends on the orientation of this
crystal so this thing was around a
vertical axis this is actually an arc
which is around the horizontal axis and
that's why it's a normal way up for a
rainbow because there's an axis pointing
to you and you end up with this arc
around that horizontal axis these are
much rarer you'll see one of these about
once a year rather than about you know a
dozen times a year what you're actually
seeing here is the crystal structure of
ice which is fundamentally driven by the
molecules within it and you're seeing
different aspects of that molecular
structure and how it forms different
crystals making these different colors
arcs can you ever get the cylinder one
without the hexagon one i think it's
unlikely because the the flat things
tend to form more commonly than the
cylindrical things so in order to get a
decent number of cylindrical things
there's probably an awful lot of flat
things around this whole thing about
crystal growth and why different
crystals form in different circumstances
is really not that well understood and
there are more complicated structures
that ice can form for example it can
form little pyramidal crystals sometimes
as well which produce a whole other set
of rocks but they are very very rare and
the reasons why different arcs form in
different circumstances is something to
do with the the properties within the
cloud where it's forming the exact state
of the humidity and the temperature and
all those kinds of things as to what
kind of crystals form um but it's really
clearly quite subtle what it is that
ends up for me so i saw something
reasonably special
you did the bright one is fairly common
but not that often seen because people
just don't look up often enough but this
one the superlateral arc really is a
pretty rare phenomenon all right i feel
like an
explorer now yeah you're a bit of a
lightweight though because there are
actually rather more spectacular arcs
that get seen sometimes just before
christmas this came out on the astronomy
picture of the day website of a set of
arcs that somebody had seen so your arcs
are actually these two at the top so
there's your circumstantial arc and
that's your superlateral paranax i
prefer to call them
i think they're reasonably you know well
known at this point so i don't think you
get to call them after you okay but
there's a whole bunch of different arcs
due to different crystal structures
different orientations that can occur
this one it's a little bit of a fudge
because the reason why the arks are so
spectacular here is it turns out that
just upwind from where this photograph
was being taken they were making snow
for a ski resort which was throwing out
lots and lots and lots of ice crystals
which clearly just got carried off in
the atmosphere to create this
spectacular display but there are
actually arcs here which have never been
seen before so there's a whole new array
of arcs which people are now trying to
understand so i got quite interested in
this on the back of your photo and
started nosing around turns out it's a
really cool piece of software that's
free to download and play with thing
called halo sim
that lets you figure out what the
different arcs are so you can actually
set up different crystals in different
orientations you can move the sun around
and see what kind of arcs you can make
and you can see that actually a lot of
the things i just showed in that picture
are here in that arc so here are your
arcs again here are a whole bunch of the
arcs related to the ones that were in
that other photo is it free software
free software free to download
i'll give that one a play the
temperature that the earth should be
with the sun where it is and absolutely
that's in fact interestingly it is about
the temperature of the moon the average
temperature of the moon is about minus
18 minus 20 centigrade
because the moon doesn't have an
atmosphere and so that really is the end
of the story as far as a body like the
moon's concerned